9-1-1 this is emergency operator 625.
i'm just gonna rob okay sir i need to
know where you are last name this is the
fire department no ma'am you've reached
9-1-1 but i can connect you to fire just
hold the line what does she look like
she was tall pink hair in heels hey man
can you tell me how long it's going to
take
[Music]
9-1-1 what is the address of your
emergency
[Music]
i just want to talk to you okay i'm
hanging out just out for a drive sweetie
okay
is there someone with you
is the person who wouldn't know you
called us no what do they think you
called your child yes sweetie does the
person you're with have a weapon yes i
need to color the car okay when i say
the right one say it's fine red
white
is it a car
no man no just yes or no just yes or no
answers enter i'm sorry i have to hang
out give me the phone right now i'm
gonna
die i have a woman who's been abducted
what are we looking for a white van
that's not enough come on
mommy might just talk to your mommy
she's gonna be okay
you promised i promise you have air
support available negative air support
is grounded due to fire weather
there is a scared little girl whose
mother has been abducted i need a better
location
i know emily is with you
where are you going
[Music]
what's going on oh my god
we need medical immediately what's going
on
have your seatbelt on
no is henry come on no
put yours on
now listen
i need you to pull the handbrake hard
[Music]
you